[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attaque et défense en même temps
qui gagne je crois qu'il compte plus
depuis un moment monsieur se détachement
a encore besoin de s'entraîner
commandant il n'y a pas une minute à
perdre oui monsieur alors qu'est-ce
qu'on fait là à jour football vous
vouliez créer une équipe monsieur
la voilà votre équipe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que
ça va pas suffire
je repasse demain de payer en liquide le
problème c'est que on a un règlement ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci pour les bières on revient quand
tu veux
[Applaudissements]
après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il était si heureux de faire équipe avec
toi
[Musique]
j'ai branché la radio magnifique
contacte le porte-avions oh
[Musique]
oh mon dieu
droit devant
non plus de munitions
[Musique]
non non non non
si ça continue comme ça on tient pas on
s'aimera pas il faut s'éjecter il faut
remonter tire sur les poignets
d'éjection quand je te le dirai minceur
on a pas le choix
éjection éjection
éjectionne et éjection
[Musique]
je suis désolé
mesdames et messieurs bonjour c'est
votre Sauveur qui vous parle veuillez
attacher vos ceintures relevez et
bloquez vos tablettes en position
verticale et tenez-vous prêt pour
l'atterrissage
salut les animal tu as l'air au top je
suis au top ou star au top du top
on se retrouve sur le pont
[Musique]